speaking of lies and a compliant press
they've outdone themselves they have
absolutely the press
and big technology and the democratic
establishment have outdone themselves
on lies in the past day and actually the
daily wire has played a role in this
so so actually i guess this show sort of
played a role in this because we
we talked about yesterday how after aoc
recalls the harrowing
experience of how she was almost
murdered during the capital riot and how
cruz was going to murder her and she was
she it was having ptsd and trauma turns
out she wasn't even in the capitol
building
during the riot so the daily wire tweets
out this headline quote
this was a headline on our website
report
aoc was not inside capitol building
during breach on january 6th
snopes a fact-checking
website just a left wing opinion website
but they call it a fact checking website
snopes rated this headline
mostly false now when snopes rates
headlines
they'll say maybe it's true or it's
false or it's mostly true it's mostly
false they will say here's what's true
and here's what's false so the original
headline was
report aoc was not inside capitol
building during breach on january 6th
snopes here's what's true wait for it
ocasio-cortez wasn't in the main capitol
building where the house and senate
chambers are located
okay what that sounds like that was just
the whole headline
aoc was not inside the capitol building
during the breach what's true
aoc wasn't in the main capitol building
where that where the house and senator
okay what's false when the attack on the
capital began
ocasio-cortez was in her congressional
office which is located in a network of
office buildings
immediately surrounding the capitol and
her office building was
one of the two buildings that were
evacuated our headline didn't say
anything about that our headline didn't
mention that our tweet
didn't mention that what we said was aoc
was not in the capitol building
then what they admitted was true is aoc
was not in the capitol building
but then what they said was false was
that we we didn't mention that aoc was
in an office building down the street
well yeah she could have been in any
building down any street
she just wasn't in the main building
that this was we were all talking about
i don't know i guess there's no way
really to appeal this sort of thing and
what do i care i don't i don't have any
respect for snopes nor do any
republicans that i know or any
conservatives
but the problem is that big technology
companies team up with companies like
snopes
to determine whether or not your social
media
accounts are going to be de-platformed
whether they're going to be suppressed
whether they're spreading fake news
whether they'll be suspended
i mean snopes is just outright lying
right they
absolutely should just delete the whole
article and fire whoever wrote it but
they're not going to do that because
they're not a fact-checking website
they're a left-wing activist group and
that's why the left-wing activists at
big tech companies
are teaming up with them because they
can provide the facade of fairness but
to say well we're just talking to the
independent fact checkers
we're just talking to the experts the
lab coats we're just following the
science
but then of course when objective
reality runs up against
one's political convenience guess what's
going to win out
you you heard jan saki you heard the
biden administration forget about that
science when it runs up against
our politics snopes forget about
objective reality
when it runs up against our politics i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you